bonjour Christian Cambon bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité ce matin
vous êtes sénateur les républicains du
Val-de-Marne président de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées du Sénat on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice
veysser Redon du groupe Ebra les
journaux de l'Est de la France bonjour
Fabrice bonjour Oriane
on a beaucoup de sujets à aborder avec
vous on va parler de la loi de
programmation militaire de la Turquie
mais on commence évidemment par
l'Ukraine et cette tournée européenne ne
veut le dire zélandski ce week-end le
dîner un truc et donc passé la nuit à
Paris hier il a dîné avec Emmanuel
Macron qui lui a donc annoncé que la
France formerait à équiperait plusieurs
bataillons avec des véhicules blindés et
des chars légers mais toujours pas
d'avion contrairement à ce que demande
le président ukrainien il a raison
Emmanuel Macron
et la faire des avions elle est un tout
petit peu plus compliquée que que ce que
l'on en dit parce que pour bénéficier
d'un appui aérien il faut effectivement
avoir un matériel le matériel doit être
piloté par des pilotes expérimentés puis
tout autour il y a toute une logistique
qui doit se mettre en place
un avion c'est 10 à 20 personnes qui
doivent l'entretenir et le préparer donc
il y a déjà sur un certain nombre de
base française la préparation
de d'ukrainien à avoir une aviation
après c'est une décision qui
effectivement peut intervenir j'ai
quelques éléments de réflexion mais
c'est au président de la République
d'annoncer le moment venu cette décision
doit intervenir pour vous est-ce qu'il
va falloir par ce qu'il va falloir
financer malheureusement compte tenu de
la tournure des événements il y aura un
moment il faudra aider l'Ukraine à
assurer son appui aérien je rappelle
quand même qu'on fait un certain nombre
d'efforts sur la protection
anti-aérienne on a déjà fourni des
missiles extrêmement performants il y a
nous avons envoyé des mandats on a un
système santé qui est un des systèmes
les plus performants du monde sur la
sécurité aérienne les Anglais ont duré
souci envoyé des missiles Storm donc
la maîtrise la France se prépare à les
envoyer ces avions
c'est pas à moi de faire cette annonce
je pense qu'il y a effectivement ce
problème est pris en compte actuellement
et le président de la République et le
ministre des Armées regarde ce sujet
avec attention il nous en tiennent
informés c'est très bien justement
l'Élysée dit ce matin
livrer les avions c'est prématuré
prématuré par rapport à quoi est-ce que
la seule explication c'est celle que
vous nous donnez c'est à dire ils ne
sont pas prêts ils n'ont pas la
formation ils n'ont pas où est-ce que
c'est un problème aussi d'organisation
interne à la France pas assez de
matériel à mettre à disposition il est
sûr que la France ne peut donner que ce
qu'elle a nous avons nous n'avons pas un
nombre de
d'avions que ce soit des rafales ou que
ce soit des mirages en l'occurrence il
s'agirait de Mirage et pas de Rafale qui
est pareil beaucoup plus sophistiqué il
pourrait s'agir de mirage mais encore
une fois moi je ne suis pas là pour
annoncer l'arrivée de dépouiller notre
armée française en livrant non il y a
pas le risque vous savez par exemple le
fait d'envoyer des AMX-10 ce sont des
chars qui sont en qui sont qui marchent
extrêmement bien mais qui sont en fin de
vie puisque ils sont peu à peu remplacés
par les avions spécifiquement sur les
avions spécifiquement évidemment si vous
si vous envoyez des avions bah vous les
avez plus c'est exactement comme les
canons César donc c'est un risque qui va
devoir être pris en compte dans la loi
de programmation militaire dont je vais
te le rapporteur ici dans cette maison
pour faire en sorte de regarnir de
garnir nos effectifs aériens nous avions
déjà vendu et prélevés sur nos effectifs
des rafales vous vous en souvenez pour
la Corse pour la pardon la Corse oulala
Kevin apsus pour la Grèce et voici bien
évidemment il faudra tenir compte de de
ces envois mais encore une fois rien
n'est décidé et de façon c'est pas au
Parlement de le décider on va revenir
sur la programmation militaire mais pour
continuer sur vos leaders qui a donc
fait une tournée Express l'Italie
l'Allemagne l'Europe la France pardon
tout ça on a un petit peu plus de 24
heures c'est le signe pour vous que la
contre-offensive ukrainienne est
imminente oui je pense je pense que
globalement ils sont prêts
il y a un certain nombre d'ajustements
en termes de matériel d'après les
renseignements que nous avons mais je
pense que le moral y est le projet est
là on voit dans la banlieue de bac
mousse un certain nombre d'offensives
qui permettent de contrer le fossileus
qui avait été annoncé les difficultés
des Russes sont connues les pertes en
vie humaine du côté russe sont
absolument
innombrables et donc je pense
effectivement qu'il peut y avoir un
non pas un retournement car nous étions
plutôt dans une situation
assez stabilisé mais il y a la volonté
de la part de l'Ukraine effectivement il
y a toujours cette volonté de reprendre
les terrains du don de base les terres
du don-basse et peut-être même la Crimée
donc on est jusque là la contrevancie
en tous les cas le don de base sûrement
puisque effectivement il y a là en
l'occurrence il y a une agression il y a
une occupation militaire donc les les la
première intention je pense de l'Ukraine
c'est certainement de reprendre les eaux
blast du gambas oui
nous n'en savons rien on a des
hypothèses mais si je le savais
inscrits européens je pense qu'il a
informé le président de la République de
ces de ces intentions et je pense que a
commencé à être évoqué la préguerre
parce que si jamais des négociations se
mettent en route démarre il faudra bien
évidemment que que ce soit aux
conditions qui assurent à l'Ukraine la
souveraineté et la sécurité et que
jamais que jamais plus une telle
effroyable crise se déclenche vous
pensez excusez-moi vous pensez que cette
guerre pourrait s'arrêter rapidement et
pour l'instant je ne pense pas je pense
que la diplomatie ne peut rien faire
pour l'instant et seul l'Ukraine peut
décider de déclencher une négociation de
déjà de cesser le feu la paix est encore
beaucoup plus compliqué à évoquer mais
je ne vois aucun signe pour l'instant
qui nous permet de dire que ce conflit
va s'arrêter ce matin dans le Journal
l'opinion Emmanuel Macron dit que la
Russie ne doit pas gagner la guerre
milique militaire au-delà des mots
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour leur
empêcher
alors je sais que des sanctions
nouvelles ont été
envisagées je ne suis pas franchement
convaincu de l'efficacité des
dispositifs de sanctions parce qu'on
voit du reste dans les résultats
économiques de la Russie que celle-ci a
réussi à redéployer vers l'Inde vers la
Chine et vers l'Asie un certain nombre
de ses capacités de production
en ce qui concerne les en ce qui
concerne le dispositif militaire ce que
l'on voit c'est que la Russie souffre
énormément a perdu énormément notamment
au niveau des blindés vous avez vu que
le défilé du 9 mai a fait apparaître
qu'un char historique on se demandait où
étaient les autres c'est tout de même un
signe et il faut évidemment que c'est
agression s'arrête car ce n'est pas une
guerre c'est l'agression d'un pays
membre du Conseil de sécurité je le
rappelle quand même il signataire de la
Charte des Nations Unies et il faut que
il faut quelque part les succès
militaires obligent la Russie à arrêter
à arrêter cette agression c'est aussi le
but de la contre-offensive pour vous de
pousser la Russie à la négociation je le
pense oui
Macron qui dans cette même interview à
l'opinion dit que la Russie a déjà perdu
géopolitiquement la guerre c'est le cas
pour vous
je crois effectivement que vous savez si
on regarde une carte du monde et qu'on
regarde le Dombas c'est vraiment une
pastille sur la carte du monde et avoir
déclenché une telle une telle guerre et
cette nuit à dos si j'ose dire près de
150 pays dans le monde c'est quand même
un véritable échec de la part de Poutine
qui pensait du reste que qui pensait
vraisemblablement je ne suis pas un
exigeait de la pensée de Poutine mais je
pense qu'il croyait que l'Europe allait
se séparer et mettre en avant ses
intérêts économiques ou essayer des
positions différentes alors finalement
ce que Poutine a réussi c'est à
rassembler l'Union européenne qui en
avait bien besoin du reste à cette
époque là et on voit que l'un de ses
plus grands échecs c'est dans l'Europe
du Nord puisque des pays aussi réservés
qui était la Finlande vis-à-vis de
l'OTAN viennent sont en train de nous de
nous rejoindre et là aussi c'est une
c'est un résultat je crois que qui
n'était pas du tout attendu par par les
Russes est-ce que vous dites comme
Emmanuel Macron que la Russie entre dans
une forme de vassalisation à l'égard de
la Chine il y a effectivement le risque
pour la Russie d'être
à la remorque de la Chine qui
regarde cette affaire avec avec le plus
grand intérêt parce que
la Russie est un immense territoire
gorgé de richesse de toutes sortes la
Russie a besoin la Chine a besoin de
moyens en énergie notamment et donc
actuellement par exemple ils font une
très bonne affaire les Chinois en
achetant du pétrole et du gaz russe à
très bas prix à très bas coût et donc je
pense qu'il y a des intérêts économiques
pour pour la Chine et qui risque
effectivement de placer la Russie qui a
perdu tous ces marchés en Europe et elle
risque de d'être dans une situation de
dépendance et jusqu'au moment où le
dresse la Chine ne supportera plus
l'état de guerre parce que vous savez
les chinois ils se sont des gens qui
font du commerce et pour faire du
commerce il faut la paix et là pour
l'instant les tensions clientèle que
même en Chine cela déclenche une sorte
de crise économique notamment au niveau
des taux de croissance et peut-être
qu'un jour la Chine trouvera que la
situation est difficile en tous les cas
nous ce que nous avons dit à nos
interlocuteurs chinois contre les a vu
c'est qu'ils avaient un rôle essentiel
pour
pour obliger Poutine à venir autour de
la table ils sont les seuls à pouvoir le
faire aujourd'hui je pense que ils ont
un rôle important il y a d'autres pays
notamment la Turquie qui gardent un
contact tout à fait important avec la
Russie et avec l'Ukraine maintenant en
ce qui concerne l'Europe c'est à la fois
difficile de fournir des armes et puis
d'être un petit peu dans le rôle de
l'arbitre on parle de la Turquie Fabrice
dans quelques secondes mais une dernière
question vous nous parlez tout à l'heure
des garanties de sécurité qu'il va
falloir donner à l'Ukraine dans
l'après-guerre quels sont-elles est-ce
qu'il faut l'arrimer à l'Europe à
l'Union européenne
je pense effectivement que
l'origine de cette guerre c'est le choix
des Ukrainiens de vivre selon les
valeurs de l'Europe valeur de démocratie
respect des libertés et je pense que
c'est cela que Vladimir Poutine n'a pas
pu supporter parce que c'était un pays
dont l'histoire est intimement mêlée à
celle de la Russie et évidemment les
Russes peuvent imaginer qu'ils puissent
y avoir un effet de contagion donc la
l'Ukraine à vocation comme d'autres pays
à rentrer dans l'Union européenne ça
doit pas se faire un n'importe quelle
condition parce qu'on a vu dans le passé
que des pays qui étaient rentrés trop
rapidement avait subi après des crises
où on avait fait subir à
l'Europe tout entière mais je pense que
effectivement
l'Ukraine a vocation à rentrer dans
l'Union européenne des des premières des
premières démarches ont été lancées vous
le savez alors évidemment tout ça est
assez long mais
ce sera un des éléments un des éléments
certains qui permettront de mieux
assurer la sécurité et la souveraineté
de l'Ukraine en Europe on parle de la
Turquie on peut absolument vous évoquer
à l'instant lors de la Turquie ces
attaches avec Moscou
entre l'actualité en Turquie c'est
l'élection présidentielle on se profile
vers on s'affiche une paire en seconde
tour pour
Erdogan deux questions alors plutôt
céréales a priori hein est-ce que ce
résultat va surprend de est-ce que ces
résultats d'une chaude fenêtre sont
fiables
alors est-ce que ces résultats nous
surprennent déjà je salue la
participation enfin vous avez vu que 92%
des Turcs ont voté ça fait rêver ça fait
rêver des chiffres qui nous font rêver
en France ça n'existe plus depuis
longtemps et je vois pas quand est-ce
que ça recommencera mes enfants donc ça
c'est quand même l'expression d'un
peuple
le deuxième fait notoire c'est que pour
la première fois il va y avoir un
deuxième tour ça n'existait ça
n'existait pas précédemment et le fait
que
Erdogan ait été conduit à tenir un
deuxième tour et quand même une forme
d'échec pour lui même si effectivement
les chiffres qui sont rapportés
aujourd'hui avec un différentiel et puis
un troisième candidat
très nationaliste dont on représente 5%
et les 5% qui manqueraient finalement
aux candidats de l'opposition pour
l'emporter donc sous ceci ne dure pas à
mon avis et encore une fois continuer
des informations qu'on a de la nuit
ne dure pas le départ d'Erdogan dans 15
jours
j'ai gagné pour vous je pense qu'il y a
des il y a des il y a des risques alors
il y a plus de 5000 observateurs qui
sont qui sont présents il n'a pas été
rapporté à notre connaissance ce lundi
matin de fraude massive mais 15 jours
vous savez c'est long et l'envie
d'Erdogan de rester au pouvoir que c'est
une envie somme toute naturelle mais
peut laisser place à évidemment beaucoup
de
beaucoup d'incidents beaucoup de
problèmes
des pays qui ont connu ça dans le passé
et il peut y avoir des pressions il peut
y avoir des manifestations il peut y
avoir des incidents qui
les autorités qui sont plutôt dans le
nationalisme ont toujours les moyens de
rassembler de leur peuples autour
effectivement
d'accusation portée contre l'étranger ce
qui a été ce qui a été le cas tout
autour de cette campagne va a priori je
pense que
à plusieurs chances d'être réélu y poser
c'est un pays qu'il faut regarder avec
la plus grande attention je rappelle que
il était à la pointe extrême de la zone
orientale des forces de l'OTAN je serai
cette semaine à l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN à Luxembourg
pour en délibérer et c'est un résultat
qu'il faudra à partir du moment où ce
résultat
n'est pas soumis à des contestations il
faudra en tenir compte malheureusement
pour la France il a pas eu des mots
tendre ni envers la France ni env le
président français la relation entre la
France et la Turquie que dont nous
essayons de maintenir la qualité ici en
France mais n'a pas toujours été très
bonne n'est pas très bonne alors que il
y a une amitié qui relie ces deux pays
la Turquie est un grand pays mais elle
connaît une crise économique absolument
incroyable 85 % d'inflation donc je sais
pas quel pays pourrait supporter ça très
longtemps on achète maintenant les
oignons à l'unité vous avez vu cette ces
reportages donc tout ceci est quand même
inquiétant
euh le problème des 413 milliards si
vous voulez d'abord c'est une somme
colossale enfin je veux dire on a même
du mal à se représenter est-ce que ça
signifie 413 milliards c'est quand même
100 milliards quand il y a une
contestation sur les 13 milliards
supplémentaires enfin 100 milliards de
plus n'est pas rien alors bien sûr il y
a des éléments qui viennent un petit peu
calmé un peu la perception que l'on a de
cet effort d'abord parce qu'il va y
avoir une part très importante qui va
être mangée par l'inflation on parle de
30 milliards donc vous rendez compte
c'est quand même énorme un 30 milliards
qui ne viendront pas pour les
équipements et puis après moi le
problème n'est pas pour moi de savoir si
c'est 413 430 ou 628 le problème est
savoir ce que l'on va faire de cet
argent et pour savoir ce que l'on va
faire de cet argent ce qu'il faut et ce
qui a peut-être un petit peu moins que
au départ c'est une revue stratégique
qui indique bien quels sont les menaces
pourquoi a-t-on une défense et pourquoi
renforce-t-on notre sécurité notre pays
c'est pour faire face à des menaces ces
menaces qu'elles sont elles d'abord
elles sont changentes deuxièmement une
voie de programmation elle va aller
jusqu'en 2030 moi je suis dans
possibilité de vous dire dans quel état
sera le monde en 2020 ou 30 qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire cet argent il faut il
faut le le dépenser pour renforcer et
continuer l'effort qui a été envisagé et
qui a été mis en oeuvre avec la
précédente programmation militaire qui a
globalement été respecté et au final je
rappelle quand même qu'on aura quasiment
doublé sera passé le 39 environ 70
milliards les moyens que la France
consacre à sa propre défense et à sa
propre sécurité il faut les mettre bien
sûr sur des équipements nouveaux mais il
ne faut pas avoir la fascination des
équipements nouveaux on a eu trop
souvent le cas où vous souvenez de cette
affaire des hélicoptères dont 50%
étaient au sol parce qu'il y avait pas
les pièces détachées il y avait pas les
pilotes il y avait pas l'entraînement
donc moi je vais faire très attention à
ce que l'on appelle la MCO c'est à dire
la mise en condition opérationnelle
c'est à dire que si vous achetez et si
vous faites construire des chars
nouveaux en grand nombre il faut aussi
par exemple que en matière de génie
c'est d'ailleurs la manière dont les
chats les
les moyens dont les chats que les chats
utiliseront pour franchir des fleuves
etc soit à la hauteur il faut que le
service de santé soit aussi renforcé il
faut si vous voulez que tout ce qui
entoure la mise en oeuvre de ces
équipements fasse l'objet d'une
attention particulière et moi je veux
demande à mes rapporteurs de bien
regarder si il y a non seulement des
annonces de matériel nouveau mais si
tout autour il y a les femmes et les
hommes et puis j'allais dire toutes les
conditions techniques qui permettront
d'utiliser ces matériels je crois que
c'est très important et ça permet de
sortir du piège de savoir si on aura
50 ou 100 charges supplémentaires alors
bien évidemment il s'agit aussi de
toutefois encore complété cette ces
difficultés que nous avons sur les
forces armées qui manquent encore de
matériel rénovés
on en vient à votre actualité
sénatoriale puisque vous êtes candidat
vous êtes candidat votre succession
je suis candidat oui il me semble qu'il
y a 6 ans vous aviez dit ça serait le
dernier ça c'est le dernier coup
j'avais pas dit les choses de cette
manière j'avais dit que je verrai dans
quelles conditions se présenteront les
élections de 2023 alors les élections de
2023 ils ont lieu dans un contexte qui
est tout à fait particulier nous n'avons
plus qu'un seul député nous n'avons plus
qu'un seul député dans le Val-de-Marne
et du reste c'est un des deux dans notre
sensibilité qui existe en
Île-de-France donc ce sont des
rapproches couronnes donc c'est une
situation donc c'est une situation
politique qui nécessite le rassemblement
sera rassemblement je suis je suis en
train de l'opérer la totalité des mers
conseiller départementaux et régionaux
de ma sensibilité
me soutient et m'a demandé de me
représenter il y a une réunion le 15
avril qui a et qui concrétiser c'est
cette ce soutien de la même manière que
j'ai nombre de nos chefs de file de nos
sensibilités qui siègent dans les villes
de gauche tous ces gens sont avec moi et
nous devons nous en ce qui concerne les
Val-de-Marne capitaliser sur les succès
des élections de 2014 et 2020 je
rappelle quand l'espace de deux
élections dans un département de 47
communes nous en avons repris 10 à la
gauche et notamment aux parties
communistes à bien évidemment il faut
que ceci est une traduction dans les
élections sénatoriales pour renforcer la
majorité ici pour renforcer l'action du
président Larcher et donc
j'en vise un de plus c'est à dire nous
sommes nous étions deux sortants je vise
je vise à un troisième siège et ce sera
je le souhaite et je fais tout pour mon
ami Sylvain bérios maire de Saint-Maur
qui va
je l'espère devenir sénateur et ainsi
assurer la transition et fructifier la
modeste influence que je peux peut avoir
dans cette maison qui sera votre
deuxième de liste puisque vous avez cité
le troisième laissez moi encore quelques
heures et quelques jours je vous assure
vous serez les premiers informés on
espère dernière question rapidement
Fabrice l'autre et là aussi nationale
on a l'impression que la droite est en
train d'essayer de lancer sa campagne
pour la prima Macron est-ce que c'est
une est-ce qu'il faut le faire
maintenant
est-ce que vous avez vous-même votre
candidat de prédilection je pense que
tout ça est assez prématuré je crois que
déjà on a un effort d'unité à faire je
pense à nos amis de l'Assemblée
nationale qui sont quand même confrontés
une partie des députés les plus jeunes
qui
n'ont peut-être pas aussi fort que nous
l'avons le sentiment d'union nécessaire
dans un groupe parlementaire donc il
faut que cet effort soit fait j'ai vu
que ce type va réunir des états généraux
de la droite bon tout ça constitue des
premières étapes mais de grâce ne nous
lançons pas dans l'élection
présidentielle vous savez trois ans
c'est quatre ans c'est un siècle on peut
pas dire de en politique donc nous avons
encore le temps de nous préparer merci
Christian Campon merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin et merci
Fabrice bonne journée bonne semaine
bonne journée et puis à la semaine
prochaine